there's far there's far more support i
mean
i'll i'll put it this way the way thomas
put it um uh
back in the 1980s thomas soul and walter
williams made a pact
never to fly together because if the
plane went down
it would be the end so we're a long way
from that today
let's talk about the doc and thomas
soule first off
when did you become aware of the work of
thomas seoul how did this whole
project come together oh well well
uh i first became aware of thomas sol
when i was in college in the early 1990s
i um
i was having something i worked for my
college paper and i was having
um a conversation about affirmative
action
uh with with one of my colleagues on the
school paper
and and another person walked over and
said you sound like tom saul
and i said tom who and i had no idea
who he was um a person wrote down
the name of a book i went and checked it
out of the school library that evening
and read it in one sitting and and spent
the weekend
reading everything else that the library
had by by thomas soul and i and i was
hooked
um and and so he he really had a big
impact on my sort of intellectual
development since since college um but i
was
already leaning more conservative uh by
the time i
i discovered time so which is i found
out later is not at all
uncommon i mean by the time clarence
thomas discovered
uh thomas soul his reaction was wow
there's someone else out there who
thinks like me
walter williams who recently passed away
had the exact same experience
um they were friends for 50 years and uh
but
when they first met walter williams was
already walter williams
um so you you you you hear this time and
again um
uh people have found their way to thomas
soul but he hasn't necessarily
led them to believe what what they what
they what they what they they now
believe
right so as a guy that writing a book
about him or wrote a book about him
that's upcoming and and did the doc and
everything
you must be just like over the moon that
he's had this
resurgence this renaissance oh yeah with
young people because when i interviewed
him i mean
the amount of emails that we got and
handwritten letters and facebook
messages and the whole thing
saying this man transformed
my life and and in many ways for me you
know people always say to me dave it
seems like you've changed so much
politically and i always say well
actually i'm mostly the same
economics is where i changed it's just
that's the one like i don't i don't deny
it right but the other stuff is pretty
much
there and and was always there but
economics is the one that really changed
and it was because of thomas old it was
happening before that interview
but to me that moment that was it that
that
pretty much was it and i and i am
thrilled that a younger generation
of people uh are interested in in seoul
um
because what he has written over the
years is as relevant today as ever
he was writing about social justice
issues 30 and 40 years ago
um he's still right about about these
things
in fact it is amazing how long he has
been so right about so many issues
uh you can go back and read personal
letters that he wrote in the 1960s to
people
about how he thought the civil rights
movement was going to end
um it's it's it's really really amazing
um his prescience in that in that regard
but and so
in terms of of me personally uh
discovering soul that's what had
happened back in college in terms of the
film
um uh well i guess i should start with
the book i i
i've been i've known seoul for about 15
20 years and i've been pressuring him
to let me do this biography for for some
time
uh and i knew i could do it without him
he said i could do it
without him but i wanted his cooperation
i didn't think a lot of
other people would talk to me um if they
if i didn't have his blessing to do it
and he finally he finally gave in and
and let me start
start writing it so i started on it
about five years ago four years ago i
got
interrupted to by someone else to write
another book about another issue so i
put the
slow book aside and then i got back to
it about 2018
and and and the result will be out in
the in the spring
uh when uh the people at the free to
choose network
and and they're the ones who produce the
documentary learned about the book
they came to me and asked me if i would
be interested in narrating a documentary
film that they were
they were putting together and um saul
had a long history with the free to
choose network uh through milton
friedman
one of his mentors who did a series for
free to choose on public television back
in the early 1980s
and seoul was participated in milton
friedman's show and so uh they wanted to
do a documentary on seoul
uh they asked me if i was interested in
being a narrator and helping and
developing the film and and that's how
that that got started
yeah there's a moment i think when i was
interviewed i mentioned this moment i
don't know if it made it into the dock
but
i'm sure you'll appreciate this when i
finished the interview with him
and i had tweeted out right before you
know i'm about to sit down with thomas
soule
you know if he's influenced you in any
way send me a message and
maybe i can read a couple to him and i
got i mean i got hundreds if not
thousands of tweets
and i said to him at the end i said dr
solo
i tweeted out that you know i'm sitting
down with you and i just got so many of
these great messages if you want to take
a look and i kind of showed him my phone
and he goes with that great voice he
goes young man
i've been doing this for a long time
and i just i just thought it was the
perfect response like truly the perfect
response
getting to what you're saying that the
things that he was talking about
30 40 years ago they're relevant and
feel new to us now
but this has been a long slog for this
guy
oh yeah yeah it it has been and and
uh there's a there's a a lot of people
think that tom is on twitter
because there's a fan fan site
and um uh it's it's run by a millennial
who's never met tom it's not an
authorized site
and all this guy does is tweet quotes
from past soul columns and books
that's it right there's no added
commentary to them he just takes these
quotes
and and tweets them out it has hundreds
of thousands of followers
which would be amazing for anyone but
especially for someone who's not on
social media like thomas solis
yeah no it really that account i mean
it's at thomas soul and for a long time
i thought it was some sort of official
account
but every time they tweet out a meme or
just a quote whatever it is and it's
like
if he wrote that yesterday you'd be
going man this guy
knows what's up and then of course you
find out oh no he wrote that
you know in 1969 or something like that
um
what's amazing and that's this this
speaks to your comment about
uh how long soul has been doing this he
he you know people often say to me
uh after i give a speech or write
something in the paper
oh it you know you must be very brave to
write something like that you know if i
write
and it's really usually if i write
something contrarian about race or
an issue like that and um uh i don't
think there's anything particularly
brave about it i think of seoul as
someone who's particularly brave i mean
he's been doing this for a long time
well before there was a fox news well
before there was social media support
or talk radio people that had his back
and that sort of thing
he was just out there writing this stuff
and he was doing it largely alone
and without the support that that many
conservatives particularly black
conservatives today have so
uh that's that's bravery in my book
what kind of support do you think black
conservatives have now because i think
you could you could probably argue it
both ways on one hand there is now some
some defense of black conservatives i
have many black conservative friends
there's
there's more out there obviously um
but on the other hand i'm not going to
have to tell you all the things that you
guys
get called and i don't even want to see
him because youtube will delete the
video
that that that comes that comes with the
territory yes the name calling has
always been there
but um but there's far there's far more
support i mean
i'll i'll put it this way the way thomas
put it um
uh back in the 1980s thomas soul and
walter williams made a pact
never to fly together because if the
plane went down
it would be the end of so
we're a long way from that today you
know and
and and uh just the support i get i you
know i i
i was a few years ago i was invited to
speak at a
college campus and then i was disinvited
to speak
i wrote a column about it um the i went
on television and talked about it
uh the the the president of the
university was bombarded
with uh complaints from graduates
uh and and even some students at the
school for disinviting me
they reversed course and
reinvited me that sort of thing i
i don't know that tom would have ever
had that kind of support
uh 30 or or 40 years ago um but but
that's what's out there today
uh for for for black conservatives yeah
do you find that his
evolution as i i talked to him about and
we had this great viral clip
where i said you know how did your
political evolution happen
you know he just paused facts you know
it's just facts that's that was what
caused him to go from
you know a marxist in essence to a
libertarian um
it seems like it's happening to an awful
lot of people right now it's not
something that the media is going to
talk about but it seems like a lot of
young people are getting it
i maybe i i maybe we talk to different
young people
no a lot of them too i know that when i
when i see the rise of an
uh alexandria ocasio-cortez um
the way she talks about how this you
know billionaires should be banned or
or um that that sort of thing tells me
something else might be might be going
on and and i think
you know part of it might have to do
with the experience i mean if you're a
young person today
and and your idea uh of
of of how uh you know an economy should
be growing or
what the employment uh should look like
in this country was the obama years
um uh or shortly thereafter
um you know that's
that's your experience and and maybe
you're you're thinking capitalism isn't
all that great of a thing if this is
you know uh all it can do um uh so maybe
you have a skewed sense of capitalism
and maybe that's where
uh people like alc come from in terms of
how they view free market economics
but i i think that republicans and
conservative intellectuals in general
i think need to do a better job of
communicating these ideas to young
people i think um
and and in a large sense they're losing
they're losing that fight now
the young people typically are are more
left of center as tom was
right when he was younger yeah uh and
and then uh
and then they grow up they go out of it
experience teaches them that another way
is better
but i do think that that republicans in
particular need to do a better job of
communicating some of these ideas
ideas to young people if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell